نقلت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه عن الاداره
العسكريه في العاصمه الاوكرانيه قول هاء
ان ثلاثه اشخاص قتلوا واصيب سته في قصف
روسي الاعلى كيف كما قال عمده كياذا
فيتالي كليتشو انه هجوم صاروخيا روسيا
استهدف منشاه للبنيه التحتيه وان امدادات
المياه والكهرباء في العاصمه الاخرانيه
انقطعت بعد ضرباته الروسيه
عن هذه ضربه معلم مراسل الجزيره المعتز
بالله حسن معتز
هذا مكان سقوط احد القذائف في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف كما تشاهدون هنا في هذا
المكان سقطت قذيفه بعد ان سمعنا صافرات
الانذار في العاصمه كياف اكثر من صوت
انفجار سمعناه في العاصمه تقريبا اربعه
انفجارات هزت العاصمه في مناطق مختلفه همم
احد الصواريخ بحسب السلطات الاوكرانيه
اصابه محطه لتدفئه المياه واا بسبب هذا
القصف اعلنا عمده كيف في تاريخ ليكو عن ان
المياه انقطعت عن كافه ارجاء العاصمه بسبب
هذا القصف الذي استهدف منشات الطاقه
التحتيه وابلغ ايضا عن انقطاعات للطاقه
الكهربائيه في مناطق عديده من العاصمه
هناك قتلها وجرحى هذه الضربات انقطاع
الكهرباء ليس فقط في العاصمه هناك الاخرى
ايضا همم شهدت انقطاعا في همم الكهرباء
الكهرباء في العاصمه كيف طبعا والمياه همم
قطعت عن منطقه الضفه اليمنى لنهار جني برو
في العاصمه المضادات الجويه كانت اثناء
هذه الغاره همم سمعنا اصواتها ايضا
وبحسب السلطات الاوكرانيه فان هذا الهجوم
هو استهدف منشات الطاقه بحسب اا ما اعلن
نائب رئيس مكتب الرئيس همم كيرينو تمشيكو
الذي قال همم ان همم الارهابيين الروسي
يحاولون تدمير منشات امداد الطاقه
الكهربائيه الاوكرانيه عفوا بحسب قوله وان
العديد من الانفجارات سمعت في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه همم كياف احد الانفجار اصابه
ايضا مبنى سكانيا هناك همم حديث عن قتلى
وجرحها في هذه الانفجارات الملتزم بالله
احسن بانكياف شكرا جزيلا لك